[Music]
who here in this room means oh you have
an embarrassing native name Oh Peppa
that's a nickname
it's a birth name right no I don't like
Spanish name or whatever right no I
don't not in my name's are Spanish a lot
of my like Spanish speaking Spanish to
be embarrassing
what was it mama mama I thought it was
mama I know but if spelled mama
mmm eh that's not the proper grammar
it's mo mmm yeah mama I'm all Mme and I
heard mama yeah ma I'm in that way
what's the proper grammar low if you
were if you were to type it out in a
book it's not ma ma are we sure yeah
it's M om ma mr. crack spelling and
that's how you spell mama I think I'm
spelling in Spanish you know like your
mama jokes right it's not me white o M
om ma alright I think yours are spelled
with two M's three amps three
yep okay mm Oh mm a is the u.s.
colloquial way for saying mother ma ma
mama is hypo court wrist usually
childish was like babies it's like four
babies today
mama no man ma ma ma or Italian mommy
[Laughter]
yeah so my name was Joe mama Joe mama
ah that's cruel damn that desert I got
me fluid out for that but it was funny
true I got made fun of my Chinese name
is a wing ho and that's also my middle
name and people always know your name is
ho yes you did laughter classic yep
you're not gonna deny it you guys are
just yeah the kids in school
hey you're the name ho in it proves true
they make matters worse my name is Casey
oh boy it is Casey also people that you
were grew up in the nineties people like
you everyone thought it was a girl's
name Casey's a hug that's a whole nother
problem right there
wasn't there a Dawson's Creek character
named Casey was it a girl guy is it
Casey Ninja Turtles have a guy so see
and I was like there's adventure Turtles
Casey yeah yeah it's QC Jones Thank You
Jones okay she was like at the popular
90s guy name yeah you would think so but
I don't know well where I was growing up
they went out of the girls name I did I
didn't know the girls and I mean either
really is Jesse you guys are going when
you think about it I look of it as he
died Jesse's girl
I think it was a guy I never met a Jesse
I hear more Jesse's as referred to as a
guy than you know Jessica is usually
with you this is my are you sure I'm
down Jess yeah Jess yeah exactly
there's jessie spano from Saved by the
Bell wait what's it is is there a longer
version of a guy named Jesse or is just
Jesse Jessica just a fur yeah I guess
that's why we mind he goes to a guy it's
like cuz that's the only name for a guy
named Jesse who's Jesse chick Jessica
yes Jesse just by every option my name
just was hard for Americans
so like answering the phone I switched
when I started working at Barbara I
started just saying Chris cranky when I
go to Starbucks and stuff I just say
Chris cuz then they won they keep not
saying answer the phone I go into deem
and they go what I'm like takes long
just Chris Antley got it I move along
and so many people like still [ __ ] up
your name gonna talk to me they say like
Nadine Nadine Nadine well even I say no
and then I say it [ __ ] up cuz I'm
trying to like enunciated better for
them oh no does the same thing he was um
his name is just DEP de vie
Indian and so a lot of people think it's
short for Devin want one funny story
actually he went on this is this hit
this hinge date and she was like so like
you know why are you.why you you know
lying to me like music watch is like you
know why you know why you're saying your
name is dev and he was like cuz it is
she's like why not say it's Devin you're
trying to like make this and he's like
no my name is dev just de Vie and she
was basically being like why aren't you
just like owning that you're racing your
hand instead of like you know what you
be real with me no actually was his name
his name is a Dev Anand so she was like
why aren't you just saying your name is
Devin on and he's like because my name
is Devin I she's like know why you're
just saying like you think be an actual
Indian he's like
cuz that's my name oh just a what that
I'm not at the last name yeah you walk
away from the date and he was like
what's that he's like super just like
casually racist on it but geez I love
them he goes to Starbucks all the time
and they go like Dez and today was
plenty sent me a text and his Starbucks
name said de D just dead yeah they're
accurate because I am dead inside yeah
that's [ __ ] hilarious that's crazy
you bring that up because this poor girl
mm-hmm her name is it the professor yeah
oh I know about how do you pronounce
that name a beard okay how do you
pronounce her Madonna I want to hear
first before you you see how do you how
do you pronounce the name she's the
enemy's American how you pronounce name
pH you see oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
no its fook is it fook I don't know
nothin I mean I heard it before okay
[ __ ] oh yeah like the movie yeah what
was that the gentlemen gentlemen yes ah
[ __ ] yeah that was [ __ ] hilarious was
a great scene shut the [ __ ] up but yeah
so she is a student she's taking a math
class declare okay yeah she's taking a
math class and and it's an online course
her teacher I didn't bother to ask her
how to pronounce her name and he just
goes right off the bat and says hey [ __ ]
you dude can you anglicize her name yeah
specifically can you anglicize your name
it's Benson can you say white yeah you
can you or can you just come up with
them more American Rachel or something
like come up with the new name right now
just just forgot ain't no American name
a Copernicus's he says in my language
I'm not trying this her full name was
like Oh Bui Bui yeah so when she buddy
when she said hey like like he
pronounced it [ __ ] boy yes yeah the
professor was like in you know in my
language it sounds like it's like [ __ ]
boy and
and if I was in Vietnam and in my life
my name sounded like eat a dick in your
language I would change it out of
embarrassment and that's what he emailed
her specifically that's bad I think I
would understand it if he came as an
approach like hey like well one in
America were trying to be more
culturally sensitive but with that it's
like hey people are still stupid they're
gonna make fun you are you'll you'll
aware of that because of your name or
would you want like us to call you
something different because people are
stupid I wouldn't even say that much I'd
be like hi any pronounce your name yes
is the normal human thing to do yes so
this guy's name how do you say a name
Matthew Hubbard that's the professor's
name he said could you use to change it
because it sounds like rondelle Hubbard
yeah the Scientology could you anglicize
your name [ __ ] fook Bui sounds like an
insult in English and then fook says
hello professor Hubbard you're a request
for me to anglicize my name feels
discriminatory and I will move forward
with filing a complaint with the title
title was a nine office if you cannot
refer to me by my given birth name and
she signs yeah [ __ ] boy and then he goes
your name in English sounds like [ __ ]
boy if I live in Vietnam and my name in
your language sounded like eat a dick I
would change it to avoid embarrassment
cropped off both on my part and on the
part of the people who have to say it
something understand you are offended
but you need to understand your name is
an offensive sound in my language he
signs off on that so I could see I could
see people overreacting to be like you
know he was just trying to do this but
at the end of the day you can see by the
way that his first email I had no
consideration it was just no he was just
like you should change it for me because
it's easier for me okay so like it was
like I could see people there's no
discussion yeah if you said hey how do
you pronounce your name because I think
I'm reading it wrong oh I think a lot of
people might make the same mistakes that
I do so you have you thought about it
but then for him and to have the
audacity of saying change your name to
something English I bet some
dumb [ __ ] I would understand that logic
if we're talking about an elementary
school child and telling their parents
hey I don't know if you've thought of
this but in this country this does sound
this way and kids might make fun of them
so it putting that on the table they got
10 more years of school left yeah but if
you're in college it's like they're too
[ __ ] adult cuz you can't teach the
kids that would make Fanny lever sounds
like a fuck-boy huh boy hey that's what
they call me people would see her
reaction me like oh she's totally
overreacting to that and it's like in
that context she looks like he's not
necessarily doing anything completely
overtly racist but you can see the lack
of any sort of empathy or compassion or
any sort of trying to understand this
issue think you're wrong I'm right why
he didn't even have a Hello in it it was
just the way you're right that he's an
[ __ ] you could take that email both
ways you could look at it as like an
attack or just so you'd be like hey like
no I'm not gonna change it but the way
she responded was accurate to how he was
saying it because the way he responded
back to that yeah horrible yeah so he
was he like yes because his thing was
just quick quick good sentence right so
you could maybe take that a different
way but the way he was going about it
was in the way she responded was
completely correct he validated his own
like shitty mindset with the first one
that was like just very sparse where he
could khana make the argument maybe he
was this maybe just said it wrong but
then when he followed up you're like no
he was an [ __ ] from the start yeah
and he totally made her it said that she
shaded a dick I want to know I think the
thing that's also hurtful is that for
many generations or just even recently
people had to anglicize from just being
treated differently like for example my
brother he's 12 years older than me
right he didn't have an English name
when he came over in class the teacher
couldn't pronounce his name and he
couldn't pronounce his name well or he
would say his Japanese name and then
hope the class would laugh at him
so because of social stigma he was
forced to change it Neil's like well
who's a cool guy
Tony Hawk's a cool guy all right so I'll
call myself Tony but he liked his name
but he had to kind of the social
pressure made him change it and I think
that now I feel like we're more of a vol
society we're breaking out of it we
could have whatever name we want right
so I think that it's weird that someone
is continuing that I guess I guess
that's the issue he's in higher learning
dude exactly someone in his position
should be seeing a whole bunch of
different you know student you know the
student body's changing every year for
him and he should have come across his
name or if not like other names and you
would think you'd be more open-minded
can we give our next kid a Vietnamese
name [ __ ] yo [ __ ] Quan I think there
might be a Quan in in Vietnamese they
might work with the cute well like later
on he's with the girl and then he's like
say my name [ __ ] [ __ ] damn yes a poor
girl yeah yeah she's right her whole
life she's always gone by the name may I
Mei or ma Y or something that may and
this was the first year she decided not
to do that to embrace her real name in
this [ __ ] hassle she's already been
through so yeah yeah she she knows what
her name special College good for
herself
yeah that's pretty awesome for me I like
more different means right I like a
challenge cuz I'm like what is that name
it's so unique and you can start a
conversation and you're like what
coaches I never heard of that [ __ ] well
how much I remember and it becomes a
game for me where I try to remember it
and pronounce it right because I like
that challenge but if it's a John and
I'm like I'm gonna forget you dude yeah
it's usually don't forget you usually
Vietnamese that's the they're kinda
interesting though because that's like I
just say Chris so often we had people
that came in they're like just walking
around the neighborhood and I was
outside they're like but oh I like we
talked to you for a second and then
there were just people like cleaning the
bugs and like because we have held like
spider webs and stuff it's like that's
that's a service they do and they're
wearing I think it was like a Bible
isn't that common and then everything
that I could sell like they're looking
at like your car like recognized
Brad's and then they're like they kind
of like recognize everything and then
you can see that I'm looking around
they're pretty jak2 and they're looking
at me and then they were like looking at
barbells trader I was worried and then
don't like Oh what's your name by the
way and I just said Chris then you see
them gonna get confused but like no I
knew who I was yeah cuz I just actually
go to Chris right yeah if I just don't
know you
yeah and like I don't I'm not gonna like
if it's a don't press on wanted me and
continue on but just pick Chris because
it's it's so it doesn't feel like me I
mean I feel like I'd be more like a
Michael or Matthews or a Oliver Oliver
I'm a Michael where am I Michael now I
have to change my name to Chris like
suck my dick or something
[Music]
[Music]